You are listening to radio lab radio lab
from
W. N. Y. S. E. N. N. P. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
the podcast. Today on the podcast,
we are going to revisit something that we explored once upon a time and a show
called new normal. You guys talk to each other now? Yeah. Hello. Hello.
Who's this? In that show we talked with a fellow named Brian Hare,
who's an evolutionary biologist. Yeah. Though that was a, that's him.
And he told us the story of a guy whose name was Dmitri [inaudible],
was a very famous geneticist in Russia. He was, uh,
alive during World War II and he's pursued by Stalin.
Had a very interesting life.
Ended up in Siberia where he began one of the most exciting experiments in
biology.
What he did is he took a bunch of wild foxes in Siberia and he kind of weeded
out the aggressive ones. You mean to killed them? Shop them? Yes,
and he did this for generations. Anytime a Fox was aggressive to people,
he would kill it unfortunately.
And then he would keep the other ones and in a relatively few generations,
I think it was 10 or so, yeah,
10 10 he was able to create a kinder and Gentler Fox.
They had foxes that were attracted to humans, which you would kind of expect.
But the thing that really got us fascinated by the Fox experiment was as these
animals behavior changed, their bodies change too. Here's that part of the show.
What was exciting and surprising was that the same foxes,
they actually show a whole suite of changes that he did not select for on
purpose. Like what do you mean physical changes?
These foxes as they became more gentle for some unaccountable reason,
their ears instead of pointing straight up flipped over. That's right.
It was a big accident that they now have floppy ears,
the tails on a Fox, which you know wild fucks. They're straight
now they have curly tails,
they have multicolored coats that are no longer just grave tips of there cause
loose color.
The teeth gets smaller and their bones became very thin.
Their bones got thinner. Yes.
So what happens to the skull and the face is it actually becomes more feminine.
The whole animal becomes more delicate than were puppy. Like, wow,
this was really a surprise to us because I mean, when you domesticate a dog,
you do expect it to become nicer to people.
What you don't expect is all this other stuff that it becomes essentially a
completely different animal. Completely or certainly differently shaped animal.
Well, that's the question really. How different is it?
Uh Huh.
Once you've become domesticated and on a household pet,
is there anything in you, anything inside that's still just a little bit wild?
Turns out our a producer at the time, Lulu Miller had been thinking about this.
Okay. And she wrote an essay,
which is not our usual style, but this is kind of fine. Yeah.
And it takes that question, you know, what's left? Uh,
what's wild that's left and it brings it much closer to home. Okay.
So here's the Lulu on most of his birthdays,
Maureen would give Charlie a sweater. Worrying was my dad's coworker,
Charlie was my dog. He was a little white terrier,
a very active little guy.
Always snuffling around at something barking graveling if you took his spot on
the couch, but when we dip him into that year sweater,
he'd go completely still and he'd get that same stillness when my sisters and I
would sit in a circle around him and color on his white far with magic markers.
I used to think he was still like that because he was happy content to be our
little dog, but now I don't know
wildness glimmered up in him though from time to time he chase after vacuum
cleaners, growl at Bongo drums and suspiciously I the dishwasher,
but he was quiet. Mostly Stoic, a good listener.
My Dad's only friend through long stretches.
My Dad's a guy prone to the nostalgic and swoops of sadness and I'd stumble in
on him on early mornings in tender conversation with Charlie testing ideas out
on him. What do you think? Big Guy. He'd say, what do you think?
I imagined he was very lonely Charlie.
That is lost in a purgatory where he didn't belong.
Okay, congratulations. You've made it this far in someone else's pet story.
I promise.
Things are about to change because it shortly after his 13th birthday,
Maureen I think got him a little blue Jean jacket with a sheepskin inside and
Levi buttons that Charlie got eaten by a pack of wild coyotes.
Well, let me back up just a step or two, and this all happened on Cape Cod,
the eastern most tale of Massachusetts where you can find beach goers in the
summer. Kennedys, I think if you know where to look, and very few predators,
a couple hawks, the occasional fox, but other than that,
as the local fauna goes, it's pretty much snow white land chipmunks,
bunnies skunks until the coyotes came.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] I was about 15 when we first started hearing about them.
And for us east coasters, it made no sense. Coyotes were symbols of the West
somewhere far, far away from Massachusetts,
somewhere where the land was orange and wide and open
[inaudible]
so I looked into it and it turns out that for a long time it was that way.
Cody's like
big states and cheerful personalities was a strictly western thing.
But in the 1920s people started spotting coyotes in New York.
And by the late fifties they'd made it up to Massachusetts only.
They couldn't quite get out to Cape Cod. See,
Cape Cod is literally cut off from the rest of Massachusetts by a canal that's
almost two football fields wide.
So for decades the coyotes were kept on the mainland until one night.
Sometime in the late seventies a pack of coyotes decided to do with the rest of
us do
[inaudible].
They gathered up their kids together for a road trip and crossed the bridge
or possibly some speculate swam across the canal.
But I think it's a far better image to picture them as silhouettes walking in
single file across the bridge with a big white moon behind them.
Woo.
So suddenly they were there and they started multiplying more and more sightings
of them in backyards and on runners roots.
The local press started running articles, keep your pets in after dark.
A cave was found local. Laura has it with hundreds of collars.
In 1998 a three year old boy was bitten.
And then
my sister found a goose completely slaughtered down on a dock by the pond.
It was surrounded by a splatter painting of feces strewn so wide.
She deemed it that of terror.
Yeah.
Now it turns out my family came to Cape Cod right around the same time as the
coyotes in the late seventies my parents bought a cabin in the woods that
overlooked a purple marsh.
The cabin had a deck and that's where we spent most of our time.
We'd sit out there late into the night watching birds and stars,
and that's where Charlie was the happiest on the deck.
He pays around occasionally nails scraping the wood,
but mostly he just flopped down with a sigh,
literal human sy and gaze out along with us.
We never needed a fence because he simply never left.
When the coyotes first showed up. I used to like hearing them.
You'd hear it as you lay awake in bed. The how will sometimes far off,
sometimes right up close. It felt thrilling to know that things were happening.
Life cycles and grizzly nature, predators prey right outside the walls.
It used to make me feel like part of the earth,
so here's how it happened. From my perspective,
it's late August. Sun Is Setting. We pull into the driveway,
but we don't see Charlie on the deck. Immediately. I knew something was wrong.
My Dad said, no way, everything's fine.
But then we heard a whimper off in the woods.
My mom and sisters and I jumped into action. We called for him,
shown flashlights, Charlie, but the woods had gone quiet
and I remember this part very clearly. We were all standing out on the deck,
craning our necks for something and just as my dad was forming the words,
look, there's nothing to worry about. He'll turn up in the morning.
We heard the Yelp, so Charlie,
that same noise he'd make when you stepped on his tail,
followed immediately by the house. I ran into a closet to hide from the sound
[inaudible].
The next morning there was nothing, not a shred, not a color,
not a bone on a piece of hair.
They say one way the coyotes do it, especially with other dogs,
is that a lone coyote comes up to the dog and starts playing with it.
Eventually they go off together and after just a few paces,
the pack descends or a slight variation.
A coyote pretends to be hurt. It whimpers and cries and calls out for help.
I can only imagine Charlie in that moment.
There he is standing face to face with his past self at long last,
I imagine his head looked up a bit, his chest swelled,
his ears perked up and he stepped off the deck.
It's right around then that we would have come home.
He would've heard us roll into the driveway seeing our flashlights heard our
calls and for once ignored us.
I wonder how fast it happened. I wonder if he even knew.
I imagine he did.
I imagine he saw the eyes suddenly all at once realizing he was surrounded and
thought I've been had well played.
My brother's well played and I like to imagine a nod of respect on their part
before they descended. The morning after it happened,
we were empty. My Dad couldn't look up.
He kept rearranging chairs around the kitchen table as if some new arrangement
would obscure the empty spot on the floor.
And for so long that's how we experienced it. It was about us,
the family member. We lacked. And then one day,
years later it dawned on my sister that for all the sadness we felt that last
moment for Charlie was probably glory for that one moment.
He was wild. He went out like a wild dog.
We were all standing out on the deck when she said it.
And my mom smiled and said, yeah, that's a nice thought.
But then she turned to us, you know,
who's to say they got him.
Uh,
who's to say he didn't often join the pack.
[inaudible]
well first of all, that was a really sad story. Yeah,
that's Brian Herr our Fox guy from the new normal show. Not too long after Lulu
wrote the, uh, Charlie piece, she and our producer,
Soren Wheeler called them up or Charlie. Anyway, um,
just to see what he thought of the story. Well, let me, let me, let me for,
can I, can I put on my totally non emotive scientist hat for the moment? Yeah,
sure. Yeah. Without you being too upset with me.
So let me ask you some skeptical questions. Have you,
have you ever heard of Mark Bekoff [inaudible] he is the coyote expert. Okay.
When he's tried to look for evidence that, um,
coyotes are doing all these horrible things to dogs. Um,
I'm just telling you what the guy argues, uh, that he can't,
he can't find any good evidence that, you know, it's coyotes that are to blame.
Huh? You mean like there's just no evidence that Cody's are even doing this?
Yeah, because first of all, coyote is darn generally pack animals. Um,
they're generally solitary and,
and so now what does travel in packs is feral dogs, you know?
But what's odd is that a feral dog wouldn't eat your terrier. Um,
so I, I'm just, I'm flummoxed. I just don't know. I'm not a coyote expert.
So are you, are you saying maybe,
let me just ask you one more question just to be sure. So this is horrible.
But Charlie was actually taken away. Yeah, I mean we didn't,
I mean we never found, there was no color, no bone,
no scrap of hair. How sure are you that it was multiple individuals? I mean,
did you see tracks or footprints or, no,
it was all just on the here on the sonic level it was like at least one,
but in my memory it's like five Howells these like,
oh, just crazy, which like yapping and, okay. All right. So,
so what that could be is it could be coyote pups. Um,
do you know what time of year it was? It was summer. August. So if they were,
you know, if they were a in the spring and by then they would have been five,
six months old. So that makes sense. And what would that mean?
Like with the pups I've done the killing or one? No, no. I think mom,
mom would've done killing. They were,
she somehow signaled to them and then they came and, uh, fed together. Wow.
So can I, so this, this is Soren.
The conversation didn't end here because actually Lou and I started to ask Brian
like, forgetting what killed Charlie or,
or what happened to Charlie, you know, is it,
is it even possible scientifically? Can can a dog,
a domestic dog somehow go back to being wild, Kinda like the Fox experiment,
but uh, the other way. Yeah.
And that's when he told us about this particular kind of dog,
New Guinea singing dogs, Guinea singing dog. Exactly.
I even have a cool recording of one of their, uh, s, uh, singing songs,
things. And they're, they're basically, um, uh,
short legged dingoes and they live in New Guinea. According to Brian. They,
they used to be just regular old domestic dogs, but a long, long time ago,
they left. Humans somehow started out on their own.
And now we have this very strange animal, which is a bit puzzling.
It's like a dog, but not,
but not quite one hypothesis is that actually they really have evolved such that
they're basically now completely wild.
They reverted back to being afraid of people.
So like what we saw in the foxes in reverse,
where aggressiveness or fear comes back. Yeah. So they,
they avoid people kind of like a wolf,
but physically Brian says they look basically like a dog. So that would be,
you know, they have the splotchy coat colors and they have a smaller brain,
right. A skeleton and all that kind stuff. Sloppy years.
They actually don't have floppy ears. Interestingly enough.
That's one difference.
There have actually been people who have said that they have slightly longer
teeth than most dogs and slightly larger heads,
which is also kind of more wolf like.
So there seems to be a couple things that are a little bit more like wolf,
but a lot of things that are still like though, I mean it's all over the place.
It's almost, it's almost like they're in between. Yeah. I mean I can imagine.
I know oddly enough,
Brian says that you can actually kind of hear that typically at night, you know,
they will start to chorus as it's called and they'll howl and, and,
and so they'll all huddled together. But it's not a wolf howl.
Woo.
Cause the wolf howl is actually very low pitched.
Whereas the singing dogs are more high pitch
and it's basically, you know,
what would it sound like if a really small dog was trying to, how like a wolf
there try hard wolves
[inaudible]
like how far these dogs are they,
are they like ballpark three generations that they've been living in the wild?
Are they just one like kicked out the back door?
Are they [inaudible] how long did it take for them to, uh, to get like that?
The last estimate I saw was 5,000 years. Oh,
5,000 years. So they've been away from humans for 5,000 years.
It's an estimate if they're 5,000 years away from humans.
I feel like what I'm learning from you about the potential to become wild again
is there's there, at least for Charlie as,
as much as I may like to imagine that moment was wild. There is no hope. Yeah.
Unfortunately. I think that's what I, I think unfortunately that's the,
that is the case. Yeah. But that doesn't mean that he didn't have the, you know,
the desire to be wild. Yeah. I mean,
I can imagine that a little guy who had been dressed up, uh,
he might've liked it, and especially a carrier. Come on, he's like, bring it on.
Bring it on. Coyotes. Come on, let's go. You know, may,
maybe he was surprised it didn't, it, you know, and it was good to have that,
uh, sort of a one shiny moment.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
thank you to Lulu Willer and our producer soar and wheeler [inaudible] Brian
Hare at Duke University. Yup. And I think that's pretty much it. That's pretty,
that's what we have to say this time. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.